All right.
Now, follow me carefully, all right.
u is some vector.
Which vector?
u, not me, u.
A matrix times a vector, since
everything is linear, if I describe u
as being made up of a bunch of
components that add up to u,
it's the same thing as sigma times
those bunch of those components.
So in particular, the components could
be the eigenvectors of sigma, so I could
express u to be eigenvector of sigma
point to whatever direction they point.
I can think of u as being made up
of the some of those, all right?
So u is a unit vector.
Okay, it can be expressed in term and
it's what it says the linear sum
of those eigenvectors of sigma.
The question is which of those
directions would return me the largest
value, okay?
Well, we know that
sigma times an eigenvector is
equal to lambda eigenvector.
If I'm going to pick a single
direction that will return the largest
vector back, and then I'm going to
take the, the dot product itself to
get the magnitude, I would need the
eigenvector with the largest eigenvalue.
And at the heart of it,
that That's actually why the eigenvector
with the largest eigenvalue
is the direction along which
you get the greatest variance.
So, you can either spend a little
time thinking about that and
understand why that's true or
you can believe me.
I guess I could have written it
out more, but I think most of you,
at this point know that I take the, the
eigenvector, the largest eigenvalue of
the covariance matrix, that's
the direction of the greatest variation.
So that's what this says here, that
the direction that captures the maximum
covariance of the data
is the eigenvector
corresponding to the largest eigenvalue
of the data covariance matrix.
Ta-da, that's what we're doing.
So, furthermore, that's the longest one,
I can take the top, I don't know,
k of them.
Orthogonal direct, and
they're all orthogonal to each other.
And that will capture the most variation
that I can, of k orthogonal vectors.
So I can say well I've got
this 10,000 dimensional thing.
Maybe I'll take the top 10, 20, 30, 40.
That captures the, as much
variation as I can with 10, 20, 30,
40 orthogonal vectors.
So that's what I, I want to use.
But in order to do that,
in order to do PCA in images,
on images I have to teach you a trick.
And this is the PCA for d much,
much, much bigger than m or n trick.
All right.
And so let's do the trick.